[Música]
y
masivas protestas en argentina
sindicatos aliados al gobierno salieron
por primera vez a las calles para
rechazar el alto costo de vida
paralelamente también marcharon
organizaciones sociales que exigían
mayores ayudas estatales para hacer
frente a la inflación
en venezuela la misión de expertos que
han monitoreado la situación de derechos
humanos en el país terminará su mandato
en septiembre un grupo de organizaciones
piden al consejo de derechos humanos de
la onu que renueve su mandato
argumentando la falta de independencia
judicial en el país caribe
en noticias de eeuu llegó a nueva york-
el mayor número de emigrantes
provenientes de estados fronterizos en
buses pagados por gobernadores
republicanos al menos 6.000 personas han
sido trasladadas en un intento para que
los territorios dirigidos por demócratas
se hagan responsables del flujo
migratorio
hola bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en argentina que vivió una
nueva jornada de protestas si bien
varios grupos opositores salieron a las
calles como es tradicional la jornada de
este miércoles destacó porque sindicatos
aliados del gobierno se manifestaron
para demandar un ingreso básico
universal esto cuando el acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional le obliga
a bajar el déficit y en medio de valores
récord de inflación que afectan a la
canasta básica luís muñoz tiene más
detalles
los sindicatos a las calles en argentina
es la primera vez que lo hacen desde que
el presidente alberto fernández llegó al
poder en 2019
también protestaron movimientos sociales
denuncian que los salarios están por
debajo del valor de la canasta básica
argentina para tener bastante claro
ante la inflación interanual en
argentina que es del 46 2% los
manifestantes reclaman más ayudas del
estado aunque el déficit ha sido
responsable del incremento inflacionario
pero la pobreza situada en un 37 por
ciento en 2021 aumenta por lo que en las
calles han pedido la aprobación de un
ingreso básico universal este
representante del movimiento obrero
explicó los motivos de la marcha
trabajo
buen trabajo
los salarios no alcanzan
a
argentina los analistas creen que la
inflación puede llegar al 90 por ciento
a fin de año además del déficit influye
el hecho de haber tenido tres ministros
de economía en un mes la devaluación del
peso y una crisis cambiaria que
dificulta las importaciones
argentinas tiene un acuerdo de 44 mil
millones de dólares con el fmi ya han
empezado a tomar medidas como reducir
subsidios y elevar facturas de servicios
de luz gas y agua afectando al bolsillo
del consumidor y en medio de
manifestaciones cada vez más habituales
y se conoció una nueva renuncia en el
círculo del presidente peruano pedro
castillo se trata del ministro de
defensa josé luís gavidia quien presentó
su dimisión de carácter irrevocable y
argumentando motivos estrictamente
personales
en febrero gavidia se convirtió en el
tercer funcionario en encabezar esta
cartera durante el gobierno del castillo
y ahora da un paso al costado en medio
de varias polémicas que rodean a su
familia y al ejecutivo peruano
un grupo de 125 organizaciones es un
llamado al consejo de derechos humanos
de la onu para que renueve el mandato de
la misión de expertos independientes en
venezuela que fue creada en 2019 con el
objetivo de investigar y documentar
violaciones a los derechos humanos ya
que dicho mandato finalizará el próximo
mes de septiembre previamente hablamos
con clara del campo encargada de
campañas para sudamérica de amnistía
internacional una de las organizaciones
que se sumó a este llamado y quien nos
contó cuál ha sido la respuesta o
cooperación del gobierno venezolano con
la misión durante estos años de trabajo
tanto en 2019 cuando se creó la misión
de determinación de los hechos como en
su primera renovación en septiembre de
2020 las autoridades venezolanas dieron
una impresión no genuina de cooperación
que se ha reflejado en la realidad en el
hecho que no han implementado las
recomendaciones que ha hecho la misión
no han permitido el acceso de la misión
al país no han colaborado ni reconocido
el mandato de la misión de determinación
de los hechos pero tampoco han
implementado las recomendaciones
realizadas o la gran mayoría de las
recomendaciones realizadas por la alta
comisionada de los derechos humanos ni
tampoco por el examen periodo un
periódico universal donde se hicieron
cientos de recomendaciones por cantidad
de estados miembros de naciones unidas
entonces no en las perspectivas de que
el estado venezolano coopere son mínimas
pero continuamos llamando a que cooperen
de forma genuina con la misión de
terminación de los hechos y este
miércoles llegó a nueva york- el mayor
número de migrantes registrados hasta la
fecha desde texas
los republicanos que gobiernan ese
estado han enviado cientos de buses en
las últimas semanas y trasladado a unas
seis mil personas con el objetivo de que
los demócratas se hagan cargo los
migrantes irregulares desde la alcaldía
de la ciudad critican que el gobernador
del estado de texas esté utilizando a
personas como armas arrojadizas a las
puertas de la campaña electoral de los
comicios legislativos de noviembre
es el mayor número de emigrantes desde
texas a nueva york este miércoles
llegaron cuatro autobuses enviados por
el gobernador republicano gregg abbott
stavanger en fort y tipo creo que hay al
menos 140 personas el recuento oficial
no está hecho su viaje de 26 a 48 horas
desde texas hasta nueva york a veces con
muy poca comida o sin nada muchas
familias llegaron con niños muy pequeños
es email sin hacer ni sobre periodismo
software aunque todavía se desconoce la
nacionalidad de los migrantes a su
llegada a la gran manzana éstos
expresaron lo difícil que fue llegar
hasta allí catastrófico realmente éste
yo estuve en peligro de aborto ella en
méxico
fue muy duro porque tampoco recibo ayuda
aquí es inmigración me dieron ayuda en
el hospital hasta el momento el gobierno
estatal de texas en manos de los
republicanos ha fletado cientos de
autobuses para trasladar a seis mil
personas que llegaron desde méxico el
objetivo que los alcaldes demócratas y
el gobierno federal asuma la
responsabilidad de los migrantes un
compromiso firme para las autoridades
neoyorquinas
el gobernador bote está utilizando a
seres humanos inocentes como armas de
guerra eso está mal condenamos esas
acciones pero la ciudad está aquí para
dar la bienvenida a la gente
proporcionarles el apoyo que necesitan y
apoyar a su llegada especialmente a los
más vulnerables a los niños a las
familias a los que no son muy
conscientes de por qué han sido traídos
a la ciudad de nueva york
a poco más de tres meses de las
elecciones de mitad de mandato donde los
republicanos aspiran a retomar el
control del legislativo
la migración vuelve una vez más a entrar
como tema de campaña
en otras noticias de eeuu el ex
vicepresidente republicano mike pence
dijo abiertamente que consideraría
testificar ante el comité de la cámara
de representantes que investiga el
asalto al capitolio el 6 de enero de
2021 si llegase a recibir una invitación
y es que pensé sería un personaje clave
ya que sus asistentes dijeron que el
expresidente de donald trump lo había
presionado para anular los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales que le
dieron la victoria a job aire
en
cualquier invitación que se dirija a mí
tendría que reflexionar sobre el papel
único que estaba desempeñando como
vicepresidente
no tendría precedentes en la historia
que un vicepresidente fuera convocado
para testificar en el capitolio pero
como yo digo no quiero prejuzgar así que
si alguna vez nos hace una sola
invitación formal le daremos la debida
consideración
50 años después del fin de la misión
apolo de la nasa y los avances del
programa espacial chino la agencia
estadounidense se prepara para regresar
a la luna el nuevo cohete lunar llego a
la plataforma de lanzamiento en cabo
cañaveral florida desde donde será
lanzado en menos de dos semanas para un
viaje de prueba sin tripulación como
parte del nuevo programa artemis de la
nasa
es el cohete más potente que la nasa ha
construido el equivalente moderno al
saturno 5 que ennio a humanos a la luna
durante la era de latón o el nuevo
sistema de lanzamiento está en cabo
cañaveral listo para seguir sus pasos a
finales de agosto llegará a la luna
llevando tres maniquíes de prueba y los
astronautas de la nasa en la tierra
estarán observando de cerca
la parte más importante de toda esta
misión es asegurarse de que cuando esta
cápsula golpee la tierra entra en la
atmósfera a 11 km por segundo para su
audiencia europea que el escudo aguante
y cuando tengamos ese punto de prueba
entonces estaremos listos para poner a
personas en el vehículo
será el primer vuelo de la misión
artemis de la nasa cuyo objetivo es
enviar a seres humanos a la órbita lunar
en 2024 con un aterrizaje lunar en 2025
los astronautas ya se están aquí matando
y los científicos están maravillados con
el regreso de los viajes lunares
de vez en cuando me doy cuenta que esto
es lo que realmente voy a hacer he visto
el apolo 13 en televisión y el cine y
voy a hacer el hombre que esté ahí
cuando encendamos los motores para dar
la vuelta a la luna eso es realmente
increíble
la misión artemis uno que lleva el
nombre de la hermana del dios mitológico
apolo está programada para ser más
diversa la nasa se propone lograr una
serie de primicias llevar a la primera
mujer y la primera persona afro a la
luna y finalmente poner un pie en marte
hasta que es informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]